you
my name is Shinya in a way I'm going to
start off by showing you a movie that I
took and then explain what the movie
means as we go along here we're seeing a
dividing Pollan mother cell of an Easter
lily and the movie is showing structures
that people had not seen inside living
cells before because people had
scientists had been fixing cells in
order to visualize those structures if
they could see them and here we see the
fibers pulling chromosomes apart and
then fiber new filaments appearing
between the separating sets of
chromosomes and laying down a cell plate
and the significance of this is that by
looking at the living cell we can not
only tell where the fibers are and what
they are doing but tell what the
molecules are doing inside them
especially what I'd like to talk about
is about how cells divide and what we
found out about how molecules come
together or fall apart and how this
plays a very important role in terms of
our cells divide now so how did this
whole thing happen well it happened
because I met as a consumer Dan he he
was a very unusual teacher because he
had taken his PhD at the University of
Pennsylvania and had come back to Japan
in 1937 with his American wife and then
I was in the first class I ever taught
in Japan and what he did was - was so
different from the other Japanese high
school I attended even let us not do
experiments that he had prescribed for
us but let us try things that were of
interest to us in the lab
and so what I did was to try Lily's iron
wrought iron wire model of nerve
conduction and this was such an
interesting project this really got me
into biology and then a few years later
when I met Freddy and his engine dance
home he showed me this book which is on
the right-hand side this was by WGA
Schmidt in geese in Germany who had a
picture that's shown in the middle those
were all sea urchin eggs in which you
see these bright or dark structures
Schmidt's lured those from chromosomes
when he wrote this book but in 1939 he
revised his view and said those were
actually mitotic spindles so this is of
interest to us and especially to Kazuma
Dan because Dan thought that the spindle
elongating was what was responsible for
what divided cells so he said let's try
and repeat this experiment of Schmidt's
and we tried once in the dark but didn't
work after the war we got back together
in Misaki at the Marine Biological
Laboratory after he recorded from the
occupation army and I built this --mess
this microscope which is a porous II
microscope somewhat different from what
is used in Neurology and it says very
good extinction poor eyes are an
analyzer and a compensator and so on
very bright light source which makes it
easier to see the various things inside
living cells and so using this we were
able to see image is so much better than
what WJ Schmidt saw and we were able to
follow what was going on inside dividing
cells so this is what started me on the
whole quest for following living cells
and masking with the pores in microscope
what are molecules doing inside yourself
the microscope that is shown here
what I built when I came to Princeton in
1948 as a graduate student and mr.
microscope I was able to show what part
of the cell was birefringence
birefringence is the word I'll keep on
using that means it has different
optical property than the rest which you
can see by using porous light
microscopes and by using polarized light
not only can you visualize the structure
that's birefringence but the
birefringence tells us how molecules are
lined up how they change and so on so
this is a special kind of microscope I
built for that purpose
now was that what I was able to do was
to first of all show that in dividing
cells they were healthy fibers they were
pulling chromosomes apart during cell
division and this was important because
when I first came it was argued back and
forth even though many people had
studied cells in after fixation that the
cells may not have been quite happy or
alive and so we needed to find a
condition where the cells were alive and
still see the fibers that total
chromosomes and those who are not
visible except by using polarized light
and the pouring microscopes that were
available then we're not good enough to
show the details so this is what I built
the microscope now what we see here the
bright structures are the birefringence
spindle fibers which had been thought to
be present but not necessarily proven
and those are pulling the chromosomes
apart and after the chromosomes are
pulled apart then you see thin filaments
which in the case of cells lay down the
cell plate and that divides the cell
into two so I have to same this you
the skeptics could not argue anymore
that these were artifacts of fixation
but we're really present inside the
living cells that was fun enough as it
was but what was really interesting to
me was to find out that these
birefringence structures were not just
there to move chromosomes and so on
but had some very intriguing properties
they would come and go here's a dividing
sea urchin egg which is about to divide
and you see the birefringence spindle in
the middle but now I'm going to drop the
temperature then raise it again drop and
raise it and as you see this is a
time-lapse movie but each time I dropped
the temperature then the butter frenzy
says rush disappears what means is that
the molecules are not bound they're
together tightly but can fall apart very
easily again drop in temperature and
this doesn't affect what the cell does
it's perfectly happy including going
drop the temperature is again
so can you even keep on doing this
experiment over and over again this
tells us that the molecules that make up
these fibers are in a dynamic
equilibrium with something they could
either fall apart or be put together
again and we'll see more of this in the
next slide here what we see is the
effect of colchicine this will not drug
known from the egyptian film even which
was used for treating gout but recently
it's been used for collecting
chromosomes because one can correct
metaphase chromosomes and use this for
the diagnosing how chromosomes whether
they are normal or not now what happened
with colchicine is when I applied Cuates
into living cells in this case it's a
all site the cell that forms an egg Oh
Marine were key copters these are my
favorite material because the cell stays
in metaphase unless you stimulate to go
further so it has a metaphase spindle
built in but then when you apply
courtesan then as you saw it will see in
the lower row the butter fringes
gradually disappears in a few minutes
then if you use a lower concentration
then as you see in the upper row then
not only does birefringence disappear
but the spindle gets shorter and shorter
and shorter and at the same time both
the chromosome to the cell surface so
from this I concluded that courtesan is
just like cold these are one of the
agents that make the spindle about to
fall apart but that what's interesting
is as the molecules are falling apart
they can generate force for pulling this
is a very strange concept that you can
make pulling force generate pulling
forces that will improve chromosomes and
the dangerous ball spins up all to the
cell surface and then if you take the
what you see in a way the reverse
happens the molecules come back together
and it pushes the chromosomes and the
Interpol towards the middle so this gave
rise to the whole concept that molecules
that are falling apart can actually
generate pulling forces now this is
seems so strange so it took 20 years
until in the test tube this was proved
to be correct one another graduated
working with us how hard for did our
another experiment he used a small spot
providers oops
the pilots light as you see in the top
second to the left panel a bright spot
of a stratified when you shine a bright
micro beam of ultraviolet light on the
spin
and watch the birefringence when you see
that spot spot itself booster
birefringence and develop an area of
radius birefringence ARB as you see
there what was very surprising is that
the city RB didn't graslie migrates to
the spindle pole and then disappears
which means that there must be some
movement oh material the spindle
material from the chromosomes towards
the spindle pole and while this is going
on the part between the chromosomes and
the ARB and between the ARB and the pole
the blood vengeance doesn't change which
meant that there must be a bio
microtubule organizing Center both at
the chromosomes and the spins of the
poles so this was quite a revolution a
revelation and when we put all of this
together then as a summary article later
on the spindle has organizing centers
both the spindle poles and right at the
chromosomes metal core and then those
are both responsible for lining up
microtubule materials tubulin but the
Cheban is constantly flowing from the
chromosomes towards the spindle pole and
estimation another shuttle is wrong this
occurs very very rapidly but in spite of
this then if we apply called or
colchicine or hydrostatic pressure
this whole equilibrium is shifted
towards the polymerization so in spite
of all this flowing and so on taking
place we get a shorter spindle and
microtubules fall and form tubulin in
this complete reversal so we have a
dynamic Librium between microtubules
which are flowing from the chromosomes
towards the pole and then which can be
made to fall apart will come back
together
fools or not the major current concept
Oh hospitals were of course there are
protein motor protein
motor protein molecules in addition to
this which also play important roles and
as people have found out recently even
that horse self on chromosome there are
40 different protein molecules that are
organizing the spindle microtubules so
the whole story gets more and more
complex and it's not as simple as I
portrayed it initially but nevertheless
the whole general scheme seems to hold
and finally there's a summary reflection
poor eyesight and I didn't get a chance
to talk about video microscopy but both
of these combined together have allowed
us to probe the dynamic behavior of cell
architecture and the structural
molecules which are far smaller than the
resolution limit of the light microscope
and we could do so directly and
non-destructively in living cells of
course there are non-destructive methods
these days these are especially powerful
approaches and still I believe that
we've only scratched the surface now I
look forward to further developments
based on here insights into the
interaction of polarized light which is
an electromagnetic wave with matter and
be broader biological explorations
through which distinct living cells
which may not be orderly used can teach
us never finder mechanisms underlying
the mysteries of nature and of life
itself so this is my summary research
thank you very much for
you